[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat de france 24 les
nations unies se prononce ce mardi sur
la reconduction des sanctions prises
contre le mali mme résolution doit être
soumise aux 15 membres du conseil de
sécurité toute la question est de savoir
si la russie la chine feront valoir leur
droit de veto la cedeao en revanche levé
cet été les restrictions imposées à
bamako s'appuyant sur l'engagement pris
par le pouvoir en place d'organiser des
élections en février 2000 24 le colonel
assimile goïta tiendra-t-il sa promesse
le pouvoir sera t'il vraiment remis au
civil lorsqu'il s'imposer par la force
en 2020 de militaires promettez de
gagner la guerre contre le djihadisme
sauf que la réalité est tout autre
aujourd'hui la menace terroriste s'étend
même à dans la sous région le titre d'
influence russe de plus en plus
grandissante notre vous invité ce soir
sont avec mon plateau bonsoir à vous
elle ni un galet bagayoko vous êtes
présidente de l'africaine security
secteur night work est l'auteur de cet
ouvrage le multilatéralisme c'est que
les états africains à l'épreuve de la
crise sahélienne bienvenue sur france 24
à vos côtés c'est dikaba journaliste et
écrivain vous êtes l'auteur de malice à
l autre afghanistan à nous un ouvrage
publié en mars 2022 aux éditions impact
et puis à ma gauche le général dominique
trinquant dont soir à vous ancien chef
de la mission militaire française aux
prêts à des nations unies bienvenue sur
le plateau de france 24 et puis à
distance depuis bamako par skype tian
belle avec guillaume bayart à bonsoir à
vous vous êtes journaliste et vous êtes
le directeur de la publication la voix
du mali vous êtes à distance mais vous
prenez la parole quand vous le souhaitez
merci d'avoir également accepté
l'invitation de france24 merci à tous
les quatre et puis vous chers
téléspectateurs je vous invite vivement
à réagir parce que c'est aussi votre
débat via les réseaux sociaux avec ce
hashtag débat france 24 on va lancer ce
débat d'abord en allant retrouver fanny
chauvin la correspondante de france 24 à
new york parce que c'est à new york que
le conseil de sécurité évidemment elle
des nations unies va se réunir tout à
l'heure à 21h heure de paris pour se
prononcer donc fanni sur la reconduction
ou pas des sanctions prises à l'encontre
de la junte au pouvoir au mali de pure
effectivement le conseil de sécurité
s'apprête à renouveler un ensemble de
sanctions pour une durée d'un an
supplémentaire
parmi ces sanctions on retrouve le gel
d'avoirs ou encore l'interdiction de
voyager pour certains individus
notamment ceux qui s'occupent s'oppose
au processus démocratique il y a un an
cet ensemble de sanctions a été voté à
l'unanimité par le conseil de sécurité
mais aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit le
contexte a changé
le régime malien a évoqué de possibles
élections présidentielles en février
2000 24 la cédéao a levé ses propres
sanctions mais surtout la chine et la
russie sont devenus des partenaires
majeurs de bamako on sait que des
paramilitaires du groupe wagner on mène
même des missions au mali justifier
comme des opérations antiterroristes par
l'ambassadeur russe à l'onu en janvier
dernier au conseil de sécurité ici à new
york la russie et la chine ont voté
contre un texte proposé par la france ce
texte qui visait à obtenir une
déclaration unis une position commune du
conseil de sécurité à l'égard de la
junte militaire au pouvoir au mali on
peut donc s'attendre s'attendre à des
divisions aujourd'hui au sein du conseil
de sécurité la chine et la russie
devraient comme à leur habitude plaidé
pour le respect de la souveraineté au
mali sans toutefois opposer leur veto au
renouvellement des sanctions selon un
diplomate joint par france24 les
occidentaux quant à eux à devrait se
plaindre de la dégradation du climat
sécuritaire au mali rappelant que 28
casques bleus de la minustah sont tombés
en 2021 enfin le représentant malien à
l'onu devrait faire part de ses
accusations contre l'armée française
soupçonnée d'espionnage au mali sans que
ce sujet soit inscrit à l'ordre du jour
de la réunion fanny chauffin en direct
depuis new york merci à vous pour ce
compte rendu ah tiens balle guy
bailliart à je vais d'abord vous faire
intervenir vous êtes en direct avec nous
depuis bamako comment est-ce que cette
réunion du conseil de sécurité et est
perçu dans la capitale malienne l'agente
plus précisément elle s'en préoccupent
one ne s'en inquiète absolument pas
les autorités maliennes se préoccupe de
cette union est latente de bamako c'est
d'examiner cette plainte contre la
france qui a une pleine grave c'est une
accusation grave la france devrait s'en
défendre et bien sûr par rapport à cette
situation grave parce que ce pays est en
guerre quand même début 2012 en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on entend dans les rues de
vaumas coup c'est ce que s'est dit en
milieux officiels et ceux qui s'essaient
qui sentant la préoccupation ce n'est
pas les sanctions que c'est peut-être
aidé ce gourmand et retour à organiser
les élections allaient en avant c'est
plutôt à la france de répondre à cette
accusation qui est jugé très grave est
gravissime à bamako dans les rues de la
capitale malienne y égaler bagayoko ces
accusations qui visent la france est ce
qu'on peut imaginer qu'elle vienne de la
russie ou en tous les cas de l'influencé
grandissante dans le pays où elles
viennent directement des émane
directement de la junte au pouvoir
moi il me semble qu'il est extrêmement
important de considérer les maliens et
les africains plus largement comme des
acteurs et de ne pas sans arrêt les voir
comme manipulés tantôt par la russie
tantôt par la france ou par leurs pairs
d'afrique de l'ouest il y a aujourd'hui
une approche à la fois patriote
nationaliste que le retrouve aussi bien
dans les rues de bamako et parmi les
élites actuellement au pouvoir et je
pense que en effet au delà des alliances
qui ont été forgés tantôt avec des
partenaires
franco-européen désormais avec des
partenaires russes il est important de
ne pas minimiser les logiques très
nationale et très local cela dit bien
entendre les fusions dans tous les cas
quitter le pays pourquoi continuer à
alimenter à ce conflit ces tensions
parce que comme je le disais il y a un
écho dans l'opinion publique malienne
un qui considèrent que la situation
sécuritaire s'est dégradée alors selon
certain regard en raison d'une
complicité de la france à travers des
accusations qui sont quand même très
très difficile à démontrer et pour une
autre partie de l'opinion publique à
travers une incapacité partagée par
d'autres acteurs comme la mine misma
j'imagine qu'on y reviendra à la faire
évoluer la situation sécuritaire dans un
sens positif sidi kada est ce que cette
dégradation de la sécurité dans les
frontières maliennes à l'intérieur du
pays mais plus largement dans la région
est ce qu'elle n'est pas aussi dû à
cette prise du pouvoir par une junte
poids oui la junte au pouvoir le fait
qu' il ait un pouvoir militaire est venu
ajouter un élément politique à la
complexité sécuritaire déjà il y a une
double crise et à l'appui sécuritaire
qui étaient là y compris lorsque le
pouvoir était celui d ib cas et à cette
crise sécuritaire est venue s'ajouter la
le la crise politique avec la rupture de
l'ordre constitutionnel normal et les
difficultés qu'il y a à conduire une
transition démocratique avec un pouvoir
qui devait à la fin permettre la tenue
des élections initiés était initialement
prévu en février 2022 et il y a eu à mes
looks ce qu'on appelle le coup d'état
dans le coup d'état puisqu'il ya un
premier coup d'état en 2000 en août 2020
et puis en août 2000 21 il ya eu le coup
d'état dans le coup d'état qui a permis
aux présents aux états de prendre la
réalité du pouvoir lui qui était vice
président en charge des questions
sécuritaires dont il y a une double
crise la crise sécuritaire et la crise
politique est aujourd'hui en avance sur
le plan de la crise politique avec
l'agenda qui a été publiée par la junte
l'agenda des élections mais la crise
sécuritaire elle ne s'est pas arrangé
puisque comme il a été dit il ya une
extension de la menace sur le plan
sécuritaire à l'intérieur du mali on a
vu aujourd'hui a récemment entre à des
zones non notamment au sud qui n'était
pas concerné jusqu'à dans la région de
kayes de koulikoro autour de bamako
puisque katy a été attaquée est précieux
et puis qui s'est étendue au delà du sel
puisque jusqu'au golf déguste de guinée
avec d'ailleurs le canada qui a subi sa
dernière attaque après le togo et le
bénin mais à mon avis il faudra
quand même aller je voudrais qu'on se
contente de l'asseoir sur la question
des sanctions est ensuite commencé voilà
on est opéra à la question de la
pression des sanctions je pense qu'on
passerait à côté si on n'exclut pas les
5 les accusations et les sanctions dans
un contexte de la dégradation de la
relation entre paris et bamako
d'accord lui la cedeao pourquoi la cdo
cet été a décidé de lever les sanctions
que j'avais été imposées à la junte et à
plusieurs personnalités de la cedeao qui
était vivement critiquée dans l'opinion
publique sahélienne pour ça son
intransigeance envers le pouvoir de la
cour a tenu compte du fait que la junte
à publier un chronogramme a publié un
agenda qui permet d'avoir une meilleure
visibilité et la cedeao a estimé donc
pour des
24 c'est ça qu'on pouvait lever les
sanctions tout en gardant de la junte
sous contrôle voir comment les choses
vont évoluer parce que le chronogramme
ne résout pas tout il y a est ce que les
dirigeants de la transition vont
participer ou non aux élections c'est
pas clarifiée il ya la question de la
rédaction de la constitution elle même
qui ne semble pas avoir obtenu un
consensus national puisque une
commission a été mise en place pour
rédiger une nouvelle constitution mais
et la cedeao a demandé au pouvoir de
bamako de créer un consensus politique
pour que l'ensemble des acteurs pour le
type il passe ip ce qui n'est pas le cas
aux jo mais comment être sûr ni à galets
manioc que cette feuille de route soit
respecté de ses engagements soient
respectés que ce chronogramme soit
honoré
comme l'indiquent ses dikaba il est tout
à fait possible de respecter le
chronogramme sans forcément satisfaire
les exigences internationales qui pour
résumer consiste à réclamer le retour
des civils au pouvoir il y a notamment
la possibilité pour certaines des
autorités actuellement en poste dans la
soeur exécutif de démissionner quelques
mois avant la tenue de ces fameuses
l'élection se pose la question du statut
des membres du conseil national de
transition y compris de celui qui le
président le colonel malick diop donc à
mon avis il ne faut pas uniquement se
concentrer sur la question du respect du
chronogramme qui à mon avis pourra
l'être mais plus largement sur la
question des comportements et des choix
qui seront faits en termes de présence
ou non dans le scrutin des différentes
autorités actuelles maintien bellaghy
mbayards as que cette demande de remise
du pouvoir aux civils et ce qu'elles
émanent seulement de la communauté
internationale vu de l'étranger ou
est-ce que c'est aussi une demande de la
population malienne
il ya le cadre de concertation des
partis politiques qui travaillent c'est
c'est un domaine privilégié des
politiques mais il ya aussi une autre
union nationale qui est là qui est acéré
gagnante qui souhaite que le toilettage
soit complet que l'agenda politique
s'achève qu'il y ait un agenda ce qu'il
est prêt lui aussi à égal de ce n est
que le mali retourne sur la scène
internationale dans des conditions
idoines en faisant le toilettage
nécessaire de ses textes et en
reprennant parole pour que l'opinion
soit soudé le peuple malien soit soudée
unie et indivisible pour faire face à
cette lutte contre le terrorisme mais
aussi à retourner sur la scène
internationale qui a suscité cette
opinion compte énormément et les
autorités de la transition ne peuvent
pas laisser de côté ou mettre en marche
cette communauté et pèse également
autant sur les politiques que sur les
autorités de la transition et l'opinion
publique malienne a tant souffert de
cette guerre de l'embargo de cette cdc
sanctions et me semble que ce n'est pas
la bonne voie de continuer à sanctionner
ce peuple qui n'a rien fait pour mériter
cette situation l'armée qui paye le prix
le plus fort de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et le pilat il faut le faire
on ne peut pas faire l'économie de cette
intervention de la france aussi il faut
s'incliner devant la mémoire de ceux qui
sont tombés français et malien bien sûr
voire même africains sur le sol du mali
pour que le malheureux pour son
intégrité territoriale
mais c'est une longue lutte c'est une
lutte
de longue haleine et cette
diversification des partenariats ne se
fait pas également au détriment de
l'occident qui clio garée maintenant il
faut une remise en cause complète par
rapport à cette politique et
nous avons petit problème technique avec
à thiant beloeil guy maillard en
attendant de vous retrouver en tout cas
vous êtes toujours va vous redonner à
paroles général train quand la france a
quitté était même chassé en tout cas
vivement invités à quitter je vais vous
donner la parole dans un instant au team
dyson et guy maillard âge interrogé le
général traquant la france je le disais
a donc plier bagages à la quitter le
mali la minustah est une autre force
étrangère en présence elle est aussi
prié de quitter le territoire il ya même
d'ailleurs eu une date indiquée par un
mouvement panafricaniste on va venir
tout à l'heure pour le 22 septembre
prochain le mali est en train d'essayer
finalement de se fermer complètement
d'essayer de deux de ne plus avoir de
surveillance depuis l'étranger pour
pouvoir agir quand je dis le mali je
pense forcément à la junte au pouvoir
oui et c'est assez inquiétant
alors les forces maliennes depuis 2013
faut rappeler que la france est
intervenue à la demande des maliens et
que l'armée malienne à l'époque n'avait
pas su résister aux jihadistes mais
l'armée malienne a beaucoup progressé
depuis elle a été formée elle a été
équipée donc elle a beaucoup progressé
mais à l'époque élèves pendant ces
années là elle a été soutenue par la
france qui combattait avec avec les
maliens elle a été soutenue d'une
certaine façon par le mali et par la
minus ma pardon et aujourd'hui elle
souhaite à la fois
que les français sont partis c'est le
fait puisque les français ont quitté le
15 août ensuite que la minus ma de toute
façon aujourd'hui à de telles entraves
que probablement la minus maël même
décidera qu'elle ne peut pas rester à
partir du moment où la liberté de
mouvement n'est plus autorisée ou les
droits de l'homme ne peuvent plus être
observés bon c'est ça clôt un peu le
débat de la minus mal le secrétaire
général adjoint aux opérations de
maintien de la paix jean pierre lacroix
était là bas au mois de juillet pour
faire une évaluation et une évaluation
stratégique qui est fait actuellement
pour être présenté au conseil de
sécurité
donc ça veut dire que les mains et les
maliens je rajoute ont demandé à quitter
le g5 sahel donc ça veut dire que les
maliens se retrouve seul avec wagner
alors wagner pardonnez-moi n'a pas fait
preuve jusqu'à maintenant de sa très
grande efficacité
donc moi ça m'inquiète beaucoup pour le
mali mais il n'y a pas eu depuis la
présence de wagner sur le territoire
malien est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu un
changement dans la stratégie militaire
des forces maliennes des femmes a
notamment à ce qu'elles ne vont pas plus
à l'offensive et ce qu'ils en changent
monstre alors elles vont à la fois plus
à l'offensive
de façon assez radicale il ya des
villages qui ont été pris ou justement
l'onu est interdit d'aller pour enquêter
parce que avec la minus m'a été priés de
quitter certains y voient là parce que
parce que il ya probablement pas mal de
civils qui ont été tués dans la région
ça c'est la première réalité la deuxième
réalité sete et cité tout à l'heure
attendez quand le camp de katy est un
cadet par les djihadistes c'est
quasiment le pourtour de bamako on peut
pas dire que wagner a été très efficace
dans ce domaine là donc il ya eu un
changement un changement important qui
ne va pas dans le sens de l'efficacité
et qui pose un certain nombre de
problèmes les pays de la région le niger
et le burkina faso ont pris des options
assez différente et je leur souhaite de
bien réussir dans les options qu'ils ont
choisi vous lirez alger
oui je rejoins le général sur un certain
nombre de points ce qui est important de
dire c'est que le mali ne s'isole pas le
mali change d'alliance c'est ça que l'on
constate la russie aujourd'hui la france
mais pas uniquement par exemple la
guinée aujourd'hui est un état qui est
considéré comme très important dans les
partenariats la mauritanie également
l'algérie le reste donc je pense qu'il
est extrêmement important de regarder au
delà de ce tête à tête entre la france
et la russie pour ce qui est de
l'efficacité opérationnelle de la russie
il n'est absolument pas surprenant de
constater
les limites pour dire le moins de cette
intervention on s'aperçoit tout
simplement que les acteurs
internationaux
ne dispose pas d'une compréhension d'une
connaissance suffisamment fine de la
complexité de l'environnement
sécuritaire locale et les russes n'ont
pas davantage de succès que les autres
partenaires internationaux est
d'ailleurs que les états sahéliens qui
font face à un adversaire
particulièrement difficile à à juguler
et qui continue de ce conseil se
propager absolument je pense qu'il faut
compléter en disant que la russie la
russie bilatérales parce que il
lorsqu'il faut pas faire l'amalgamme
souvent entre wagner et la russie
bilatérales parce que il y à la russie
bilatérales et il y à wagner les
distinguer bien sûr la russie
bilatérales c'est une coopération
ouverte entre un pays que le mali et la
russie la fête de la fédération de
russie
historiquement la russie a été un allié
de bamako depuis modibo keïta depuis
l'urss l'union des républiques
socialistes soviétiques mais on n'agit
pas sans les sanctions sévères du client
ni profession qui a entretenu
volontairement entre battner et la
russie où on sait pas qui est qui mais
non c'est que moscou refuse de
reconnaître la présence de wagner sur le
salut l'indus et les maliens qui sont
absolument clean que voilà c'est pas
nouveau en centrafrique aussi
officiellement on ne reconnaît pas la
présence dé wagner puisque c'est un marc
site mercenariat et ça fait pas crédit
vous pourrez en état de contracter les
services d'une compagnie de mercenaires
mais chaque je voulais simplement ajouté
c'est le la coopération bilatérale avec
la russie a permis à bamako d'acquérir
un certain nombre d'avions un certain
nombre des mig un certain nombre de
souris qui ont facilité la mobilité des
forces armées maliennes sur le plan
opérationnel
c'est une valeur ajoutée indiscutable
maintenant c'est que ce qu'il faut
regarder à côté de cette de cet apport
russe que effectivement sur le terrain
le rapport de force n'a pas changé
l'association ne s'est pas du tout
améliorée et donc le départ de barkan
l'arrivée de la russie l arrivée de deux
de wagner n'a pas permis de changer en
tout cas sur le plan de la territoriale
et sur le plat même de l'efficacité
pourquoi les arrivées centré sur outreau
on est arrivé à une sorte de complexité
même dans les opérations conduites par
les djihadistes on a vu
exceptionnellement dédié à dist conduire
cinq ou six attaques coordonnées en même
temps sur le territoire malien ça ce
sont des faits nouveaux à mon avis on va
y revenir sans doute la solution reste
aussi dans la coopération sous régionale
avec les pays du g5 savel avec c'est
peut-être vers ça qu'il faut alors
général trinquons ya un redéploiement
des forces françaises au niger etc on
sait à quoi cela va ressembler oui bien
sûr parce que le niger a pris la
précaution et je salue d'ailleurs la
méthode qui l'ont employé de présenter
ça au parlement est d'obtenir un accord
du parlement le président du niger l'a
fait les sens civique pardon je ne sais
pas la france et oui mais ça n'a rien à
voir et donc pour parce qu'on n'a pas de
force étrangère ils sont là en france
pour lutter contre donc le président du
niger qui a passé un accord avec la
france l'a fait passer par le parlement
pour avoir un soutien sur ce sujet là et
là
le déploiement français change
radicalement d'abord en volume à peu
près la moitié 2500 personnes en suisse
un mix voilà ensuite un soutien et
d'ailleurs je souligne que dans les
dernières opérations
j'ai regardé dans les derniers quinze
jours et beaucoup d'opérations qui ont
été menées par le niger sans soutien des
forces françaises c'est à dire que les
forces françaises n'interviennent que si
le niger le mans c'est à dire qu'elles
font le choix d'être plus discrète bien
sûr d'être plus discrète et de fournir
des moyens dont ne disposent pas
directement le niger des avions des
drones des hélicoptères quelques forces
spéciales et donc c'est lorsque le niger
le demandent qu'à ce moment là la france
interviendra au profit du niger donc je
pense qu'effectivement comme vous le
disiez il ya un changement de visibilité
évident 1 et puis un changement de
méthode mais il faut rappeler que cette
méthode arrive après ses tempes
coopération le niger a recruté dix mille
hommes dans les trois dernières années
et ses dix mille hommes il fait là fallu
les équipes et les entraîner et on
considèrerait souvenez vous de la fin de
l'opération barkan c'était le sujet dans
la zone des trois frontières en
particulier qui était de dire maintenant
ça n'est pas nous qui les français qui
sommes en avant ce sont les africains
nous sommes en soutien en accompagnement
c'était d'ailleurs l'objet la force
takouba la force européenne
d'accompagner les africains donc il ya
un changement de méthode est évident et
on va faire justement réagir vous êtes
toujours avec nous tu rebelle guy
maillard a voulu réagir aux propos du
général traquant
l'opération back and sait pas gérer mais
on n'a pas fait le bilan on n'a pas tiré
le bilan de l'intervention de la
communauté internationale
auprès du mali aps on ne peut pas
prendre aussi les autorités actuelles et
le peuple malien responsable d'une
diversification de ses relations
militaires avec d'autres pays et ici on
ne parle pas de wagner du tout on parle
de coopération avec l'état russe on
parle de l'équipe type
inscriptions à la mairie de montée de
puissance de cette armée malienne qui
est une réalité en terme d'organisation
des cadrages du territoire mais le
résultat est là aussi tout comme avec la
communauté internationale
cependant je crois qu'il faut plutôt
encourager les autorités mahler
encourager le peuple mais aidé le comar
et prendre exemple sur eux
la cedeao qui est revenu sur ces
sanctions impopulaire et qui accueille
qui a observé et constater que le peuple
malien a payé le prix fort des crises
pandémiques du copic 19 de la situation
générale mondiale et communication
vous dites qu'il faut soutenir le peuple
malien je vais citer le mouvement hier
et où est l'eau qui se présente donc
comme panafricaniste qui a organisé des
manifestations hostiles à la présence
française qui a aussi prié la minus m'a
quitté le territoire malien avant le 22
septembre prochain dans quelle mesure il
faut l'encourager ce peuple malien qui
manifestement ne veut pas d'aidé
étrangère
il ya une opinion publique malienne qui
est là est rigolo s'inscrit dans cette
logique de refouler toute intervention
et toute ingérence c'est son droit le
plus absolu mais c'est pas l'opinion
exclusive au mali il ya une haute
opinion qui est là il ya bien sûr
d'autres formations politiques qui ne
rentre pas dans ce quatrième c'est deux
doigts d'euros mais ce combat là qui ce
pas pour cela c'est une réalité et même
cette montée en puissance dans l'opinion
publique malienne de cette tendance dès
hier où l'eau est due en partie au
manque de résultats est due en partie
aux relations scabreuse entre la france
et le mali est dû en partie au fait que
le président mac os le fait que m me
piquer par le mali ne fais que citer le
mal est partout où il passe en algérie
et ailleurs il faut remettre en cause la
politique française au mali remettre en
cause de l'intervention de l'opération
de cerval jusqu'à berkane qui est laid
les autres et pour le mali et pour
l'afrique pour une lutte efficace
médicaments oui je sais pas c'est qu'il
faut dire je pense que comme il a été
dit aujourd'hui il y à une chape de
plomb il faut dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont qui fait que le débat
interne au mali beaucoup de partis
politiques et beaucoup d'intellectuels
n'avait plus à s'exprimer librement on a
vu par exemple des figures de la lutte
démocratique comme
docteur marco disparaître parce que il a
tenu une opinion qui étaient divergents
dont je pense que la junte aussi le
pouvoir en place au mali rendrez service
en favorisant de la discussion il ne
faut pas qu'il est simplement la posture
de ceux qui ne veulent plus dead etc ce
qui ne me paraît pas honnêtement très
réaliste dire que le mali peut se passer
de l'aide étrangère ou de la coopération
avec ses voisins parce que les rapports
avec le mali sont difficiles avec la
cedeao sont difficiles avec le niger
aussi qu'ils sont beaux ces contenus bon
de inimitié qui lie à entre la junte le
pouvoir de niamey etc mais tout ça ne
participe à de l'amélioration de la
sécurité les enjeux ce n'est plus les
considérations subjectives personnel
entre les pouvoirs malien où ça mais
c'est dans les populations du sahel ont
besoin c'est la sécurité pour pouvoir
aller aux champs pour pouvoir aller au
marché surtout dans le contexte
aujourd'hui de la crise iranienne qui a
un qui a fait flamber les prix de
denrées alimentaires se donnent les
populations ont besoin c'est la sécurité
je pense que ça c'est le principal enjeu
et c'est ça qu'il faut construire
au-delà des autres considérations
ce qui me semble important en effet à au
delà du caractère de plus en plus
autoritaire et des restrictions de
liberté très grave qu'on constate
aujourd'hui au mali c'est plus largement
de concevoir la nouvelle stratégie au
sel comme n'étant pas purement militaire
et l'alliance avec les russes apparaît
toujours sous cet angle là et ce qui me
paraît intéressant aussi du côté du
niger pour compléter ce qu'indiquait
général c'est que la stratégie du
président bazoum et multidimensionnelle
il ne faut pas oublier que le président
bazoum a engagé un dialogue aussi et ce
sera une question difficile à mon avis à
résoudre pour la france parce que le
début de ses différends avec le mali non
pas avec la junte mais d'ores et déjà
avec le président ib cas a précisément
porté sur cette question du dialogue est
ce qu'aujourd'hui pour les partenaires
internationaux avec les groupes
terroristes avec les groupes terroristes
et y compris côté nigérien ce qui
n'était pas le cas au mali avec le plus
sanguinaire d'entre eux c'est à dire
l'état islamique au grand sahara qui a
une approche beaucoup plus aveugle en
termes d' attaques contre les civils que
le groupe gcim affiliés à al-qaïda donc
cette question de l' approche
multidimensionnelle fondé à la fois sur
le dialogue politique non le voit aussi
dans leur région du lac tchad sur la
question de l'amnistié d'un certain
nombre de combattants se pose aussi je
pense que vraiment d'une manière
générale il est nécessaire de sortir de
ce prisme de cette lecture beaucoup trop
militarisé des solutions apportées au
sel bien entendu l'instrument militaire
est nécessaire mais dicté doit être mis
au service d'une approche politique de
la gestion de la crise générale traquant
le militaire que vous aimez d'accord le
tout servi en avant mais je
je suis d'abord tout à fait d'accord les
approches ne peuvent elles que
multidimensionnelle l'outil militaire
n'est qu'une partie de ce sujet le niger
laborde bien mais permettez moi de dire
que c est le reproche qu'on faisait au
mali c'est à dire que le mali
refuse à refuser barkan après les coups
qui étaient là mais au départ en fait
n'avait pas non plus une approche
multidimensionnelle ce que reprochait
les militaires français quand il était
sur le terrain et c'est très bien on va
combattre un mouvement djihadiste à un
moment on va les chasser mais comme
l'état ne revient pas ben ils reviennent
et nous ça a servi à quoi à rien donc il
ya cette approche est depuis très
longtemps le problème de l'outil
militaire c'est qu'il est à la fois trop
lourd trop présent on se concentre là
dessus et ça évite de regarder le reste
des aspects et ça les militaires qui
sont sur le terrain le savent très bien
et ils vous disent quand ils vont dans
un village oui mais où elle met maître
d'école où est le préfet c'est là que
viendra la p1 et pour revenir alors moi
je connais beaucoup moins bien que les
deux autres interlocuteurs l'intérieur
du mali de la politique malienne
j'entends mais je suis toujours un petit
peu choqué quand on parle de l'opinion
publique ça veut dire quoi l'opinion
publique ça veut dire quelques parties
ça veut dire des manifestations sur une
place à bamako comment peut s'exprimer
il ya plus de parlement élu enfin je
veux dire récemment élu il n'y a plus
vraiment de capacité et vous le disiez
dans dans le dialogue il ya un certain
nombre de pareils qui ont dit on n'y
participera pas donc moi je dis
simplement qu'est ce que c'est que
l'opinion publique c'est une question
que je pose à je n'ai pas de réponse est
apportée à ça c'est à dire que vous
faites sens avec les manifestations
clairement stylo présence française on
n'a pas vu de contre manifestations
contre mobilisation c'est à ça que vous
faites allusion notamment oui moi je
suis voulait les contre-manifestations à
bamako bon il y en a pas eu j'ai vu les
soldats français qui quitter les zones
et dans lesquelles les populations
étaient très triste de les voir partir
c'est tout ce que je peux dire tiens
belge yves maillard a voulu réagir oui
énergie pour dire que le mali il faut
pas se tromper là dessus est loin d'être
un pays seul parce que cette lutte du
mali aujourd'hui répond à une certaine
opinion
j'ai même au delà du mali qu'est ce que
c'est que l'opinion publique c'est
l'opinion qui fait pression sur les
autorités qui a serré gadal par rapport
à la gestion des affaires du pays qui
demandent de faire un bilan par rapport
à une opération militaire c'est aussi
simple que ça qui demande à tirer les
leçons d'une lutte contre le terrorisme
qui demande plus de résultats sur le
plan sécuritaire de le tour de
l'altération
hic puisse de la population dans leur
quotidien ou les aides on les assiste et
on les accompagne c'est normal j'ai eu
je vois que même sous cette démocratie
c'est pas la même france qui a laissé
tomber du bout de bras le président élu
yves rocard qui était qui devait
terminer son mandat en 2023 ce n'était
pas la même france qui a éliminé double
données qui a fait 1 mois avant de
l'annoncer ce n'est pas la même phrase
qui intervenait changer serval de touba
impasse à berkane jusqu'à apte à pouvoir
sans associer les populations sans
associer le peuple malien c'est et
pourtant cette france a été bien
accueillis en libérateurs mais la
finalité elle est là il faut le
reconnaître il faut l'assumer il faut
maintenant partir sur de nouvelles bases
discuter d'égal à égal posez l'intérêt
général du mali et l'ont tiré 29 ici et
continuer à un croc en jambe des visites
en algérie pour incriminer le malien de
manu dépasser le ballet avec l'algérie
et le mali avec tous ses états qui
veulent aider un respectant la dignité
l'intégrité du mali et le peuple malien
dans son choix et ça c'est important
même en démocratie le choix non moi je
crois que on a une fenêtre d'opportunité
comme a dit nadal est
aujourd'hui la conviction qu'on a c'est
que le tout militaire et sécuritaire n'a
pas donné autant de résultats qu'on a
attendu et malheureusement
avec même l'arrivée de la russie de
wagner tout ça on reste à le tout
militaire maintenant on a une fenêtre
d'opportunité avec sept réalisations
de barkan le retrait du niger pour
asseoir un nouveau paradigme qui
inclurait le multi militaires et
sécuritaires mais qui inclut aussi la
question du développement la question de
la gouvernance la question de la
présence de l'état parce que quand on
prend un phénomène comme l'inde
organisation que l'on observe
aujourd'hui le fait que
les fantassins comme les chefs de katiba
soit des locaux soient des maliens
soient des nigériens c'est pas une
question qu'on peut combattre avec
l'outil militaire seulement il faut le
développement la plupart des jeunes qui
s'emballe pour cent mille francs qui
s'emballe trop 150 mille francs c'est
parce qu'il ya un terreau favorable il
faut que la question du développement
soient intégrés dans le nouveau
paradigme est à mon avis il faut naïl
fenêtre d'opportunité si on ne sort pas
du tout militaire et sécuritaire on
risque de se retrouver encore dans des
années à faire le bilan d'une situation
sécuritaire au sahel qui ne s'est pas
améliorée mais vous évoquiez 7 vous
évoquez l'instant cette responsabilité
de l'état de miser aussi sur le social
pour éviter que cette jeunesse par
exemple nay finalement adhéré aux idées
à l'idéologie même deux groupes de
groupes djihadistes mais je reviens sur
la minus mas qui a donc été appelé à
quitter le territoire elle n'était peut
être pas utile dans la sécurisation du
territoire mais ce qu'elle n'a pas joué
un rôle justement dans le développement
socioéconomique de du pays et est en ce
sens et ce qu'elle n'a pas comblé une
défaillance de l'état malien
malheureusement non c'est à dire que là
aussi je pense que cette sueur
focalisation sur les succès limité voire
les échecs de l'intervention militaire
fait qu'on ne se concentre pas sur les
échecs qui malheureusement sont tout
aussi patent des interventions civile
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on se trouve
face à un tournant avec des politiques
de développement des politiques
d'ingénérie sociale et institutionnelle
qui sont en échec de manière indéniable
et il est très difficile de continuer à
répondre à des acteurs qui eux
développent justement non pas uniquement
des approches tactiques militaires mais
par exemple une approche par le droit
c'est extrêmement intéressant ce qui se
passe dans le centre du mali où les
groupes djihadistes administre la
justice à la place de l'état un recours
en recueillant que dans un certain
nombre de motards inviterait la maison a
de manière arbitraire ça ça reste à de
manière violente souvent de manière
arbitraire ça
par exemple sur des textes de loi
la charia oui mais est-ce que c'est
perçu comme arbitraire par les
populations pas nécessairement la façon
dont certaines katiba par exemple la
katiba du macina gère la répartition des
ressources dans le delta du niger ça
aussi c'est une façon de combattre
l'état donc je pense qu'il faut aussi
penser réfléchir à des réponses face à
ce type de tactique qui sont extrêmement
fine qui permettre une insertion très
profondes dans l'environnement social
plutôt que de se concentrer uniquement
sur les différentes attaques même si
bien entendu il faut aussi répondre
alors vous avez plaidé pour moins de
sécuritaire plus de dialogues d'essayer
d'instaurer en tout cas des échanges
avec ces groupes et ce qu'ils y sont
disposées tout d'abord ça dépend
lesquels et surtout la condition posée
par ceux qui sont disposés en
l'occurrence les groupes affiliés à
al-qaïda donc le gcim c'est le départ
des troupes étrangères et on a très bien
vu que la façon dont a été présentée la
succession d'attaqués qui ont eu lieu à
la fois à cattier dans le centre du mali
par justement le gcim c'est de dire que
c'était une réponse à l'intervention des
russes aux côtés des forces maliennes à
moi où l'on accuse ses deux partenaires
d'avoir commis de très grandes d'un
grand nombre d'exactions et le gcim
refusé également de dialoguer tant que
les forces françaises et les forces
onusiennes n'auraient pas quitté le
territoire donc oui ce sont des acteurs
politiques et qui ont leurs propres
revendications avant d'arriver à la
table des négos de dialogue il faut le
reconnaître lydiane du dialogue a
beaucoup évolué initialement le pouvoir
malien celui d ib cas était celui qui
voulait le dialogue et il y avait un
malentendu sur la question avec la
france comme il a été si bien rappelé
aujourd'hui l'idée du dialogue à gagner
le niger et la revendait le burkina faso
au burkina faso au tchad
le saas est un dialogue avec le
politique ce n'est pas l'été avec le
pianiste et c'est ça la différence mais
mais le dialogue avec avec les groupes
djihadistes a un peu évolué le niger le
présent bazoum a assumé l'idée de faire
le dialogue au burkina faso aussi le
dialogue donc il ya une évolution de
l'idéal même maintenant ce sont sa mise
en oeuvre aussi à laquelle il faut
réfléchir avec qui il faut discuter
comment il faut discuter d'un pays à un
autre la réflexion n'est pas la même le
burkina par exemple veut que ce soit les
leaders religieux les chefs de groupe du
groupe qui discute avec le jihadiste
alors que au niger par exemple l'état le
présent bazoum a dit qu on a permis la
libération d'un certain nombre de
personnes qui étaient détenus à la
prison de haute sécurité de koutoukalé
pour qu'elles puissent devenir des
intermédiaires donc et l'idée l'idée a
beaucoup avancé elle est devenue
d'une minorité est là elle a beaucoup
avancé il ya trois pays aujourd'hui qui
sont les plus concernés en réalité dans
le jsl c'est le niger le burkina et le
mali qui sont le plus concernés par la
question sécuritaire c'est bien c'est
vrai que le tchad de la mauritanie font
partie g5 mais ils sont moins
véritablement a fait affectés donc cette
idée de dialogue et à évoluer il faut
maintenant réfléchir à la façon de la
faire et il faut savoir quel type de
concession qu'on peut faire il est
important de voir que il y à déjà dans
certains villages du mali que des
populations elles mêmes ont commencé à
faire des accords locaux avec des brides
ya liste il faut éviter que cela se
propage et il faut donc encadrer ce
dialogue là en essayant de réfléchir
pour éviter justement que des accords
locaux comme ça puisse se développer et
sans qu'on puisse avoir un véritable
contrôle là dessus
oui non simplement au dire que le
dialogue et le dialogue et la
d'élimination de avec qui on discute et
qui ont combat c'est un peu la
responsabilité des états quand même donc
c'est leur responsabilité et je le
répète comme le disait très bien
niagalén tout à l'heure le développement
de ces états islamiques si vous voulez
dans les différentes dans les différents
dans les différentes régions existe
pourquoi parce que l'état est absent et
qu'il faut que l'état vienne passent des
accords voient comment ça peut être
gérée mais c'est de sa responsabilité et
c'est son absence qui crée ce set l'aide
la nature a horreur du vide qui crée
cette possibilité pour des mouvements
radicaux brutaux parfois de se
développer dans ces régions là juste un
point simplement sur la visite du
président macron en algérie je voudrais
rappeler que le président macron son
intérêt premier lui c'est la sécurité de
la france et que le dialogue avec
l'algérie ont fait partie voilà c'est
tout
alors allez-y tient bel qui brille
on a quand même constaté le rôle du haut
conseil islamique au centre du pays un
certain moment donné ce n'est pas plutôt
des accords locaux entre cours
puisqu'une c'est une pédagogie pour des
radicaliser parce qu'on ne peut pas
quand même éliminé physiquement tous ces
gens qui se sont retrouvés de l'autre
côté de la barre de la base de toutes
les façons il y a des irréductibles
parmi qu'il n'y a aucune ci qui n'est
que l'élimination on a également
constaté que l'élimination le décapite
âge qui était la stratégie française
jusque là n'a pas fait recette à la
matière n'a pas permis d'éradiquer et
surtout le péché originel qui est
empêché l'armée malienne teintées à
kidal a conduit à cette catastrophe là
et alimenter encore davantage ce
sentiment anti français on a entre
certain temps prêcher un mandat robuste
de leurs aînés de la minus pas au mali
pour pouvoir élever un peu
l'accompagnement à la résistance la
lutte contre le terrorisme ça n'a pas
été le cas aujourd'hui cette diversité
situation avec la russie qui entament
eux mêmes une action coordonnée du mali
a au mois de novembre prochain avec
l'algérie et le goret aussi tes pensées
étaient avec l'algérie et je rappelle au
générique en caisse le mali qui a servi
de base arrière à l'algérie pour se
libérer et que le président algérien a
même que tu y as à carreaux et il a eu
un accompagnement des populations
maliennes et ce lien descend l'algérie
aussi réductrice du mali que de la
france ce n'est pas le problème des
relations franco algériennes mais c'est
plutôt aussi donné
mali à travers cette rapprochement et
même cette commission cette commission
mixte militaire qui skie propre qui se
profile à l'horizon omar novembre
prochain entre l'algérie et le ont
précisé que l'algérie lorsque le
président macron étaient sur place qu'il
a donné sa conférence aux côtés du
président tebboune lorsque emmanuel
macron a parlé de la nécessité de lutter
contre l'impérialisme russe le président
et bouna et c'est
en fait je pense que toute intelligence
tout accord entre la france et l'algérie
pourrait profiter au mali l'algérie est
un acteur important de la question
malienne par exemple lorsque il y a eu 7
cet accès de tension entre la france et
l'algérie et que l'algérie a interdit
aux avions militaires français le
survoler son territoire sa a impacté les
choses si la france et l'algérie peuvent
travailler ensemble pour avancer la
cause la question de la sécurité au mali
pourquoi pas on a pu savoir que à
l'occasion de ce déplacement lors de la
réunion qu'il ya eu entre les chefs
d'état major français le président
tribune et le présent macron plus le
patron des services de renseignement la
question du sahel a été abordée il est
incontestable à mon avis de considérer
l'algérie comme un acteur important si
au lieu de la rivalité entre la france
l'algérie on peut construire
mais plus généralement je pense que quel
que soit le partenaire des états
sahéliens ou africains plus largement il
doit concevoir la relation bilatérale
dans le cadre de partenariats élargis
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment la tendance
que l'on constate chez toutes les élites
quelle qu'elle soit on parlait du niger
aujourd'hui le président bazoum a des
alliés comme la turquie par exemple la
russie est un partenaire extrêmement
important en terme d'équipement de
l'armée nigérienne également et je pense
que le temps est révolu où se nouer des
partenariats privilégiés qui relevait du
tête à tête quel qu'il soit et je pense
que ce qui va être un peu novateur dans
les diplomaties des années à venir va
être la façon dont les états vont
réussir à s'imposer dans le cadre de ces
partenariats qui seront choisis par les
états africains qui indéniablement
veulent les diversifiés merci beaucoup
et ce sera le mot de la fin 6 h f ce
débat merci de l'avoir suivi merci à
vous ni à galets bagayoko s'est dit kaba
dominique tra quand et puis tiens belle
guy maillard a en direct depuis bamako
merci à tous restent avec nous sur
france24 informations critiques